revista de prensa en directo América de
Francia 24 abrimos nuestra revista de
prensa de hoy lunes con Marta Moya Marta
bienvenida Gracias por acompañarnos como
siempre nos vamos hasta Irán porque los
medios locales hoy titulan en sus
portadas con la doble moral de occidente
sobre el uso de las fuerzas policiales
concretamente citan a Reino Unido esto
también por esta confusión que hay sobre
si se va a desmantelar o no está
polémica publicidad de la moral iraní
vamos con el Ivan Daily si Raúl buenos
días vamos a empezar con el Iron Daily
que titula en su portada impresa el
Primer Ministro británico promete
aumentar los poderes policiales para
reprimir las protestas todo esto como
decías no después de la polémica que ha
habido sobre si se va a disolver o no la
policía de la moral Richi es una que el
Primer Ministro británico dijo que va a
dar a los policías lo que necesiten para
reprimir a los manifestantes en un
momento en el que se prevén huelgas y
manifestaciones por el alto de vida o
por esta situación económica que vive el
país en los últimos tiempos no el cambio
climático también está entre las
previsiones de las manifestaciones y
esta portada era ni crítica ese doble
rasero que tiene occidente concretamente
Reino Unido vamos ahora con el Times en
la misma línea Raúl aplastadas en
occidente alentadas en Irán vuelve no a
esta cosa sobre si el Reino Unido puede
decir que sí aumentar los poderes de las
fuerzas militares o las fuerzas de
seguridad del estado en este momento
mientras critica el hacer de las fuerzas
de seguridad iraníes en el marco de las
protestas que empezaron en septiembre
concretamente cita el turan Times al
portavoz del Ministerio de exteriores
más cercana Ani que bromeaba ayer en
Twitter sobre este doble rasero diciendo
los líderes de estos regímenes ahora
presentan su definición deseada de
disturbios y protestas después de
calificar el terrorismo bueno o malo
también Marta repasamos que dicen los
medios iraníes independientes en el
exterior sobre estos últimos
acontecimientos dentro de Irán esto en
el marco de las protestas Pero antes
Vamos a repasar un artículo del medio
británico de Guardian sobre un llamado a
una posible huelga general sí Raúl el
Guardian titula así manifestantes
iraníes llaman a una huelga de tres días
mientras aumenta la presión sobre el
régimen los medios estatales como
decíamos se han distanciado de estas
calificaciones del fiscal general de la
nación diciendo que se lleva a disolver
la policía de la moral porque el fiscal
de la nación no tiene la competencia
para decidir el futuro de la institución
en medio de la confusión se hizo un
llamado a tres días de huelga general
para seguir presionando al gobierno
incluida una gran manifestación el
miércoles en la plaza asadi en Teherán
estos llamados se dan en los últimos
tiempos no que se ha traducido en una
estos llamados perdón a la huelga
general se han traducido en los tiempos
en una escalada de los disturbios
veremos qué pasa en estos días no el
domingo después de una reunión a Puerta
cerrada entre altos funcionarios con el
presidente del gobierno risi un
legislador dijo Después que el gobierno
estaba bueno prestando atención a las
demandas de la gente también un también
destaca este artículo del Guardian las
declaraciones del enviado especial de
Estados Unidos en Irán que dijo que el
gobierno de Rise está en un círculo
vicioso con su represión de las
protestas no dice Tal cual Mientras más
se reprime en Irán más sanciones hay
contra más sanciones más aislamiento
contra más aislamiento más acercamiento
a Rusia Cuanto más acercamiento a Rusia
más sanciones el clima se deteriora más
para una diplomacia nuclear también
Estados Unidos destaca este artículo
prevé votar a favor de la expulsión de
Irán en el comité de la ONU sobre la
condición de la mujer que está prevista
Raúl para el 14 de diciembre mar
International sí Raúl y este es un
artículo que destaca que se ha filtrado
un audio en el que 80 manifestantes
iraníes se enfrentarían a la pena de
muerte este audio es una filtración de
una reunión de miembros del régimen
concretamente del Consejo de las fuerzas
de la Revolución islámica que es una
coalición conservadora dentro del
espectro político iraní en este audio
líder de la coalición le pregunta al
secretario que le cuente Cómo van estos
últimos acontecimientos y él dice el
portavoz reza de Bari que 80 personas
entre ellas 10 menores de edad estarían
acusadas de delitos de enemigos de Dios
y corrupción en la tierra que ambos
delitos se castigan con la pena de
muerte el ayatola habría pedido que los
detenidos fueran ejecutados sobre la
base del principio de quisas que evoca
el precepto islámico del Ojo por ojo
pero con eso solo Se podrían ejecutar a
10 personas por tanto se prevé que los
ejecu por estos delitos de corrupción en
la tierra y enemigos de Dios avanzamos
Marta
titula una joven iraní detenida durante
46 días por un tuit nos referimos a
París sarabi que publicó un solo tweet
criticando al gobierno iraní a este
bueno fue llamada primero a la comisaría
por la policía del internet la liberaron
Un día después y después la volvieron a
llamar y detener y posteriormente
encarcelar en estos más de 40 días en
prisión se le ha privado de atención
médica porque esta joven fue operada
días antes de su detención de un tumor
cerebral y se le ha negado cualquier
acceso a medicamentos incluso la policía
también ha negado a la familia que se ha
trasladada a un centro hospitalario
rápidamente cerremos con un análisis del
New York Times en el que repasa a través
de los vídeos en redes sociales Cuál es
la magnitud de estas protestas actuales
en la República islámica sí Raúl Perdón
que me quedo sin voz No te preocupes
hacemos referencia primero la quema de
estructuras y símbolos de estado no esto
es una respuesta al fracaso del gobierno
con el compromiso de la sociedad civil
después de anteriores manifestaciones el
segundo tema es el luto público en otras
manifestaciones en los familiares de
personas que habían sido ejecutadas por
las fuerzas de seguridad habían sido
alentadas a guardar silencio y ahora se
han mostrado manifestaciones de luto
público el tercer motivo es el liderazgo
de las mujeres que ya se vio en otras
protestas pero nunca en esta dimensión y
el cuarto motivo que destaca este
análisis del nortems es la solidaridad
generalizada y es que pues todo empezó
con el asesinato de una joven kurda de
una minoría y ahora las protestas sean
sabido transversales tanto a escala
geográfica como social y étnica Gracias
Marta como siempre por toda la
información y bueno su última revista de
prensa de este año un placer haber
compartido con usted y pues ya en enero
o en febrero el próximo año seguramente
nos vemos la cara aquí en revista de
prensa Marta gracias gracias a ti Raúl
un placer un placer y nosotros